Dumbledore can make mistakes he said
they all blinded by hate you're not yes
you are
how did they make it past the editing
stage are you one of the muggles who
missed these Harry Potter movie mistakes
stay tuned to find out the Harry Potter
film series has captured the hearts of
fans of all ages including us here at
the things but there are some places
where the spell of movie magic kind of
fell flat
here are some Harry Potter movie
mistakes that only muggles missed
someone who is muggle-born someone with
non-magic parents someone like me in
Harry Potter and the Chamber of Secrets
Harry and Ron try to enter platform 9
and 3/4 only to have the portal closed
on them before they can make it through
our poor heroes end up crashing straight
into the wall with all their luggage
tumbling down around them if you look
closely though you'll see Harry's pet
owl Hedwig is actually a fake her cage
even opens and the fake owl hangs limply
on its perch at least the producers
cared about animal cruelty Harry Potter
and the order of the Phoenix introduced
us to guppy
Hagrid's giant half-brother what do you
meet Harry in the gang he gets a little
too excited though and grabs Hermione
from the ground it looks like the CGI
team at something to hide
put me down they digitally cut off
actress Emma Watson's legs at the calves
it's only visible for a split second and
it's hard to see in the dim lighting of
the scene but that didn't stop some
Ardenne fans from catching it what's
going on
now back to the Chamber of Secrets the
students at Hogwarts school are still
uneasy about the mysterious happenings
in the castle everyone will proceed to
the dormitories immediately so their
teacher Gilderoy Lockhart is asked to
teach them how to protect themselves in
magical duels after Harry sends Malfoy
flying in their practice duel you can
see one of the film's cameraman at the
edge of the shot looks like muggle
technology has made its way to Hogwarts
uh Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
Part 1 is one of the darker movies in
the series Harry and his friends spend
most of the movie on the run from
Voldemort's cronies trying to find the
Horcruxes as harry and hermione sit on
some rocks trying to find some clues
about where to find the Horcruxes a book
beside Hermione opens between shots but
maybe this one's not such a big deal
since we know that some books are
capable of attacking unwitting students
we'll let you decide speaking of books
there's a scene in Hagrid's care of
magical creatures class when the book
bronze holding simply vanishes and
reappears between shots maybe he was
practicing his vanishing spell but come
on Ron now is not the time to be doing
that you should be focusing on the
magical creatures the Triwizard
Tournament was a dangerous competition
in the Goblet of Fire
Harry faces a vicious dragon and an
angry look and mermaid among other
things but maybe he wasn't in so much
danger after all at the end of the movie
he gets two scratches on his left cheek
only for there to be just one scratch in
a later scene as he's saying bye to his
friends maybe he's got healing powers or
something or did the makeup team just
forget to check what they did before I
put you in terrible danger this year
Harry I'm sorry
lots of equipment used on set or
battery-powered it's all part of casting
movie magic but as you can imagine
filmmakers try their best to hide these
gadgets from the audience while it
didn't work this time in the prisoner of
azkaban we can see the impression of
battery power packs under Daniel
Radcliffe and Emma Watson's clothes in
that scene in Hagrid's pumpkin patch
another case of muggle technology at
Hogwarts in the order of the Phoenix
when Harry is having Voldemort induced
visions in his sleep we see him asleep
in a light blue t-shirt when he's
startled awake though he's wearing a
completely different dark blue button
shirt maybe this is a case of that
accidental wand 'less magic underaged
Wizards tend to do or maybe the
filmmakers didn't think we'd see it part
of the spectacle of Hogwarts as the
floating candles we see them in Harry
Potter and the Sorcerer's or
Philosopher's Stone
after Professor Quirrell comes into the
Great Hall and announces the wires are
caught on camera beside Professor
McGonagall if you look close enough
you'll see the wires holding them up
movie magic at its finest going back to
that scene in Chamber of Secrets when
Harry and Ron crash into the wall
there's one more mistake that did not
make the cutting room floor Ron's trunk
makes a complete switch in one scene his
trunk has three copper lines running
across it but then soon after we see a
similar trunk with only two copper lines
maybe wizard trunks are capable of
Transfiguration at will what do you
think that's gonna kill me
as Harry starts his journey in the
Wizarding World in his first year at
Hogwarts mm defa codes very different
code he's sorted into Gryffindor House
during the post sorting feast Harry is
seated across from Hermione and next to
Ron for a while anyway in the next shot
Harry's seated between Ron's brother
Percy and Hermione I thought no one
could disappear on Hogwarts grounds does
Harry know something we don't
the scene when Harry accidentally calls
the night bosses a pretty fun one in
both the Prisoner of Azkaban book and
movie but chances are you did not see
this little mistake when we look at some
bus curtains in a small window from the
outside we see that they're hung up
completely differently from how they
look after Harry steps inside another
case of sentient inanimate objects do
you think Lee Hallows Part 1 brought
back Dobby a fan favorite the house-elf
is devoted to Harry for setting him free
from the slavery to Malfoy in the
Chamber of Secrets free Dobby the brave
little hero is Dobby and other house elf
creature attack a man in order to help
Harry and his friends that's not what
the mistake is though as Dobby and
creature step out into a room different
objects entirely are resting on the
table when they're attacking the man
later though we see a table beside the
door with a black pan on it movie magic
at its finest
the Weasleys have always treated Harry
like family in the half-blood Prince
he even stays at their house in the
start of the movie in a scene when he's
sitting on a sofa beside Ginny and her
father Arthur there's a blanket on the
arm of the sofa it doesn't stay there
for long though in the next shot it's
behind Harry on the back of this sofa
what's with these wizards and they're
moving objects very early in Deathly
Hallows part-2 Harry and his friends
visit their Luna Lovegood she's not who
we're focusing on right now though the
trio go and talked to the Goblin named
Griphook who looks like he's seen better
days as the scene wears on the cushion
grip hooks resting on slides down even
though Griphook barely moves at all a
small mistake but there must be a
magical explanation right this is
impossible alone yes but with you know
the Goblet of Fire film doesn't give
poor Ron a break he gets dreadful
hand-me-down robes from his mother to
wear to the Yule Ball in the scene where
he reacts to the ugly clothes the toast
in the caddy in front of Harry on the
table in the Great Hall changes
depending on the angle toast vanishes
reappears and rearranges throughout the
scene do you think the crew got a chance
to eat some of it at least I sure hope
so
Quidditch is a dangerous sport in the
best of circumstances when a dark wizard
who's possessed by Voldemort himself is
trying to get you it's even worse after
Harry's broom is hexed - during a
Quidditch match by Professor Quirrell
Harry falls off and has to hold on for
dear life if you freeze the shot you see
the wires that hold Dana Radcliffe to
the broom so he wouldn't fall they are
extremely thick wires so you know
they're strong safety first looks like
he's going to be safe
[Music]
Jiri has always been a selfless soul in
the second task of the Triwizard
Tournament he defies the merpeople
who tell him he's only allowed to bring
one person back to the surface with him
when he makes his way back to dry land
he's joined by Hermione who's wrapped in
a dark towel throughout the scene though
the towel changes from dark to light and
back again well hey at least she's
drying off the Goblet of Fire is when
the Harry Potter series takes a dark
turn
Voldemort is back and everything changes
for Harry and everyone else before he
restores baltimore's body though Peter
Pettigrew aka Wormtail stove's
voldemort's wand inside the left side of
his coat when Valda boards back to full
power and demands his wand from Wormtail
though he pulls it from the right side
of his coat well they do say wands are
semi-sentient maybe it moved on its own
that proved yourself useful these past
few months we all hate Dolores Umbridge
she torments poor Harry and all of
Hogwarts in the order of the Phoenix
when area is said to UM bridges office
to be punished for basically nothing
umbrage puts sugar in her tea before
placing the spoon on a saucer throughout
the scene the spoon appears and
disappears from the saucer between shots
I'm sure we all just wish that the spoon
would stay gone just so she wouldn't be
able to put sugar in her tea it's the
least she deserves I'd say did you
manage to catch these mistakes as you
watched the films we poor muggles
definitely didn't if you know of any
others be sure to leave them in the
comments and don't forget to Like and
subscribe for more content from the
things